Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait.
MOUBOO!
Kairi no-sai-maseen!
Go-shin-Ninya-mao, Go-in-yoo, rever-wo-go!
Hello, hello, welcome in, welcome in!
Welcome into...
Aoi and Wake!
Woo!
Boo, bo, bo, bo, bo!
I think there's not like a spoilers on this, right?
You know how some, like, Openings kind of have like a...
Hey, don't watch this unless you've played the game already.
Alan wake up!
Did you decide to play this because its creator is
considered the European Kojima?
No, I decided to play this because everybody said that Alan
Wake 2 is so good and that's all I wanted to play.
I had no idea.
I have zero idea what this game is about, you guys.
I literally know nothing.
I am going in, like, 100% blind, basically.
I did zero research.
So...
Please try to avoid spoilers and all that.
We're going to implement the smiley method, where if anybody
sees spoilers in the chat, please do a smiley face so that I
do not see it.
If I see a smiley face, that tells me that I should not look
at chat and that also pushes the spoiler off the screen so
that it gets no attention.
It's my foolproof method.
Hello, Mito and Ibu is like you.
I wish upon every Ibu good health and many blessings this
year.
Love you.
Ah, Kamu, thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
I don't know.
Good system.
Yeah, it seriously has been like the best system yet.
Because like I said, not only does it push the spoiler off
the screen, out of chat so I don't read it, it also alerts
me that I should not be looking.
Oh my gosh, right before stream, I went to go get...
It was during the loading stream.
It's just loading screen.
I went to go get some tea.
And I saw Paz running around, and she loves to, like, hide
in my room.
And I go back into my room, and I was like, there better not
be a little girl in here.
Paz is my cat, by the way.
I'm like, there better not be a little girl in here.
And then I check behind the curtain, and there was a little
girl, but I had already shut my door.
And so she was, like, freaking out because she just went to
the bathroom, so she had the zoomies.
She goes to run outside my door, and she sees that it's
shut, and so she's like, what do I do?
And so she freaks out, and, and, and turns around really
fast and booked her head on the wall.
Payment for the slap earlier.
Thank you, Minto.
I needed it.
Kapo!
Kapo.
Be happy.
It's okay.
It's all okay.
I'm so happy to see you getting a start in the Remedy
universe.
Is that what it's called?
Alan Wake is a fantastic foothold into Sam Lake's dog shit.
Affectionate.
Who's Sam?
Wait, what are...
What is...
What's happening?
Today's my birthday today!
I can't think of a better way to spend it than by watching
Minky!
Oh gosh, see my happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday, happy birthday!
Sorry for being in the comment that tipped the tear bucket
yesterday.
No!
It's totally okay.
Totally A-okay.
Do Smiley's a random plot point, so Minto always questions
what could possibly be spoiler- No!
Don't do that!
Just do smileys.
I mean, you could if I start trying to like guess stuff, you
could do smileys.
Don't ever confirm or deny nothing.
Confirm nor deny nothing.
That's like confirming something is like a big spoiler.
Oh, I don't know.
Am I alone in thinking that way?
Always smiling.
ABS, always be smiling.
Alan Wake is about Alan who's awake.
I don't know, I've never played the game.
Me neither.
Well, he's clearly awake in, like, all of these.
Oh, sure.
Oh, my gosh.
Thank you so much for the 15th of day.
Thank you.
Um, but what was I gonna say?
Oh, people would make fun of me sometimes because I would
make up, or I would make up.
make I would I would mix up Alan Wake and John Wick because
okay you have to be you have to understand now all I saw was
Alan Wake too that guy looks exactly like John Wick and so
in my brain there I had so that's also partially why I
wanted to play because I finally watched Alan Wake and now
I'm finally no sorry wait no I just did it again I finally
played John Wick.
No, wait, I did it again.
I finally...
I
finally watched John Wick.
And now I'm finally playing Alan Wick.
And so hopefully I won't get them confused anymore.
I can't get him right.
Oh my god.
Get him right.
Oh.
Oh, geez.
Also, I got Alan Wake this one and the second one when they
were free on Epic Store.
So, yippee.
Also, thank you guys for the super chat.
Sorry.
I was...
Did you know Alan Wake isn't his...
Don't say that.
Don't...
That's his real name.
Love my dyslexic Oshi into assassin slash author dudes.
That's our Vtuber.
It's your theme music.
What's the theme music?
His real name is John Wick.
Oh...
I think you're confused.
You're like Alan Wick and John Wake again.
Wait.
Alan...
No, it's Alan Wake and John Wick.
Wait, no!
You're confusing me!
Wait, it's Alan Wake!
It says it right there on the title.
And John Wick.
Don't do this to me!
Alan Wick.
No, Alan Wake.
Alan Wake up.
Can't wake up.
John Wick.
Punch you in the dick.
I think that's how I'll remember.
Because John Wick will be upset that you killed the dog.
I have to think of something else for Alan Wake though.
This is how I found your Kamiyoshi in 2022.
She was playing Alan Wake on Twitch.
And this is how I fell down the VTuber Rabbit Hole.
Henya!
Alan's the monster.
Wake is the scientist.
Dr. Allen and Wake Hyde.
Keanu Reeves' real name.
Keanu Reeves.
I feel like that has to be his real name.
That's like such a specific name.
Keanu Reeves.
I'm Googling it.
Real name.
I was right.
I don't think you'll ever be able to get rid of the John
Wake.
No, John Wake!
Sam Lake is head of Remedy and made the games.
Ah, he's also the face of Maxpan.
Oh!
I live two hours away from Remedy's HQ where this game was
made.
Oh my gosh, cool!
So cool!
The actual name is Neo.
Ouch, oh my gosh, I might not be able to wear my...
headphones today.
I might have to switch out.
I think they're online.
I think I scratched my ear earlier and it made a cut.
I'm gonna switch to my big headphones.
One second.
Today, today, today, today.
Oh, I also gotta get my controller.
This is a controller game, right?
I'm like assuming this is a controller game, right?
La la la, can you hear me?
Wait, I did it.
Unplugged my mic, I unplugged my headphones.
Hopefully Alan Wake doesn't go after them nuts or your
method will be ruined.
You're so right.
Oh my gosh, what if that's his signature move?
Amito just got home from the mall.
Did I miss anything?
Uh, we're about to wake up, A.B.
His real name is Frank Yeager and Yeager is driven for Wake.
Alan Wake, bake you a cake.
John Wick, punch you in the dick.
Where's my controller?
Alright.
Wait, yeah, if this guy is considered European Kojima, is
this a movie game?
I love that.
Windows jump scare.
Sorry, that was me grabbing my controller.
This guy you play as a guy and he's a dude.
Spoiler.
Press any key to play Bum
Does the game seem quiet here guys Shall we start?
Very excited to say Mito start this This game Very Twin
Peaks, very Twilight Zone Ooh, I'm so excited Mystery in
Adventure Hall It's not quiet Really Okay, cool Let's go
then Oh, is this game difficult?
Would you guys say, what would you say is normal okay to do
for me?
This isn't a movie game.
This is a book game.
My name is Alan Wake and I'm a writer.
Normal is fine?
Okay, okay, okay.
I think normal is fine.
Okay.
Alan, it's time to wake up.
Alan, wake up.
Let's wake up.
Stephen King once wrote that nightmares exist outside of
logic, and there's little fun to be had in explanations.
Wait, do I need some- They're antithetical to the poetry of
fear.
Can I put on subtitles?
In a horror story, the victim keeps asking why, but there
can be no explanation.
I don't want to press start in case it skips it.
The unanswered mystery is what stays with us the longest,
and it's what we'll remember in the end.
My name is Alan Wake.
And he's a writer.
I'm a writer.
Ah!
I've always had a vivid imagination, but this dream
unsettled me.
It was wild and dark and weird, even by my standards.
Even by your standards.
What are your standards?
So yes, it began with the dream.
Super chat writer.
Alan, wake up, girl.
Following a typical nightmare pattern, I was late,
desperately trying to reach my destination a lighthouse for
some urgent reason i couldn't remember i've been driving too
fast down a coastal road to get there oh my god that's scary
oh my god be safe wait this is the dream right i've seen the
hitchhiker too late why was he standing in the middle of the
road though
he was dead i was convinced they'd put me in jail and i
would never see alice again Alice.
Your lights.
Oh my god, Alan, wake up!
Alan, wake up!
It's just a dream!
Draco's, thank you so much for the time.
He gets a thank you!
Suddenly, his body was gone.
Episode 1, Nightmare.
Whoa!
I was in shock from the crash.
I could hardly stand my feet.
Okay, give me one second, I'm going to...
Oh!
Look to the...
Wait.
R...
Okay, turns the camera.
Look up to the light.
Reverse your...
No, I think...
I'm actually one of those people that like...
If I press up, I like to look up.
So...
No, I'm okay.
You can change camera settings in the menu's option screen.
Okay, one second.
Let's see if there is subtitles enabled.
Sorry about that, everybody.
So sorry.
Also one second.
Let's do that.
Up is up.
Yes, yes, yes.
Andrew goes, did I say thank you?
I said it in my brain.
Thank you so much for the tori genta.
Thank you.
I don't know if I said it out loud.
Please, no, thank you.
And Ralph Walgood, welcome back.
Thank you.
I like to imagine that this guy does voiceover for
everything.
I woke up and went to the kitchen.
I ran out of orange juice.
So true.
Alright, here we go.
There we go.
Oh, do I need to make the font size?
We'll do it like this.
That should be good.
Oh.
He walks so funny.
LB, the sprint.
Oh.
That's a funny button, the sprint.
Drop hazard.
hazard of blah blah blah's called drop the beat now I had to
go to the lighthouse I knew there was something important
waiting for me there get to the lighthouse oh did that just
give me wait what is what's the red thing up there wait I'm
gonna sorry we're still adjusting right now I think I'll
make the font a little smaller because I'm gonna be blocking
it quite a bit so we'll make it like that I think probably
this is the remaster well it was the only one that I had on
up on my epic store so they're like hey idiot the lighthouse
is over there what's over here though the bridge is out the
bridge had collapsed I'd have to find another way to the
lighthouse pick up coffee thermos collectible okay that's
fun narration is kind of sending me the the sensitivity on
the camera is look at that it's kind of insane I'm not gonna
lie holy cow it's gonna take some getting used to actually
all of these controls are gonna take it's very it's like
slow and sensitive at the same time oh shoot wait I was
gonna read that though ah you don't even recognize me do you
writer you think you're God oh shoot Oh, she did.
Well, maybe she did.
Oh,
uh, maybe I should run.
Maybe I should run.
What's this?
Missing.
There's a robot and a QR code.
Maybe I should run.
A to jump.
E!
Oh my god!
It's like I'm actually running in a dream.
It's kind of insane.
You missed your deadline!
You can dodge enemy attacks.
LBLS to dodge.
Okay.
Ah!
You can't stop me!
Can I punch?
Try it again.
Dodge the attack.
Where'd he go?
I realized that the hitchhiker was a character from the
story I've been working on.
Funny.
Run, Minto.
I was.
I was running.
Can I get back over there?
Look at the way he jumps.
Safety!
Welcome back!
Thank you!
Rider Dodge.
Woo!
Oh!
Okay.
We're getting to the lighthouse.
Something spooky is gonna happen here.
I know.
die by the hands of your own please oh boy I think we need
to run no we need to run oh
my gosh I'm just a rider I have no stamina
run run please oh someone's helping me I'm running I'm back
Alan run.
Alan wake up and Alan run.
I'm here.
Waddle for your life.
No time to lose, you say.
No, no.
Our friend.
What were you doing?
Stuart?
Stop.
Two bullets and a dream.
Oh my god!
Clay Stewart!
I was trapped.
There was no way out.
Uh, I can hide in here.
Oh, I can just push the whole...
I can push the whole ass everything.
Move the bed.
What's happening?
Can I push this?
Oh my god.
I had to get out.
Um...
How do I get out?
Whoa!
If I could, um...
Ouch!
Wait, hold on.
Follow the light.
Okay.
Hmm.
I'm running?
Oh, that's...
you should go into the light you are only safe there oh yeah
go into the safe haven focus oh I'm focused whoa whoa well
done I have something important to be directed by God for he
did not know that beyond the lake he called home lies a
deeper darker ocean green where waves are both wilder and
more serene to its ports i've been to its ports i've been
being do you understand to its ports i've been
to its ports i've been i entered your dream to teach you the
darkness is dangerous it's sleeping now when it feels you
coming it will wake up helen wake up there's no time i can
only show you the most important thing the hidden Each hiker
has been taken over by the dark presence.
You can't hurt him now.
The darkness protects him from all harm.
Only light can drive the darkness away and make him
vulnerable again.
Here, take the light.
I'm trying, but it's only telling me to get the...
I'm focusing?
Pick up the flashlight.
Oh, sorry.
I thought that was the flashlight.
Okay, yes, sir.
Turn your flashlight toward him and burn the darkness away.
Whoa.
You did it.
Now the darkness no longer protects him, but it's still
inside, controlling him.
He can't be saved.
He's still a threat.
He is still your enemy.
Yeah?
Here, take the gun.
The gun.
Oh, shoot.
A revolver!
Pick up the revolver.
Okay!
My goodness!
Uh, uh, there it is.
Okay, I'm seeing...
Now you'll die.
RT the fire.
Oh, oh, shoot.
Heck yeah.
I jumped.
How do I...
Oh, okay.
I, like, get him, and then I shoot him.
Interesting.
I'll reload.
Oh!
Oh.
Oh, shoot.
Ah, bubba.
Oh, ouch.
Oh.
Ah!
Ouch!
Oh my gosh.
I keep jumping instead of dodging.
Good.
You've done well.
Remember what I've taught you.
Thank you.
That is all.
I will give you back your dream now.
A terrible darkness was taking over the world.
The lighthouse was the last safe place on Earth.
Okay.
Let's grab all that we can get now here.
Oh, I didn't limit reach.
But I have no more battery.
I hope that's okay.
The last safe place ever, ever.
Oh, shoot.
You're back?
I just killed you, though.
Oh, shoot.
That's real.
Yeah!
Tap X to reload faster.
Okay, cool.
I'm running.
I hear...
Sorry.
Oh my god, there's more of them!
Oh my god!
Oh shoot.
Ouch, I'll...
Oh shoot, I'm gonna die for real.
I gotta get out of here.
Get in the light!
Oh my god.
Pick up flare gun ammo Take that, I guess Flare gun Use the
D-pad to switch weapons and throwables I guess that would
help if I Um Uh, what's the word?
Oh, you know what he really needs is one of those Uh,
flashlights that you shake And that's what recharges the
battery gosh okay so we need the flare gun i guess to like
get good light i could hear him like i can hear like
spookiness breathing
you did just oh my god there's three of them uh wait um
let's run i think they wanted me to do that go to the light
Alan run Alan run oh wait the sign even said Alan wait how
do I jump?
Jump Alan oh
that's a barrel
I'm running in my dream.
It's running in slow motion for real.
Come on!
Collectible!
Collectible thermos!
Pick up!
Oh, I missed it!
That's okay!
Run!
Alan drink!
Wait, I thought this place was supposed to be safe!
Alan butterfingers!
Alan slip!
Alan fumble!
We really are just like running in slow motion, it just
feels like a dream for real.
Uh oh.
Certified Hood Clash.
He's here.
Alan?
Wake up?
Oh, they said it.
Shh, baby.
Just another nightmare.
Everything's fine.
You dozed off.
Right.
Alice?
More than dozed off would be news for everyone.
Oh.
Cheer up, handsome.
We're here.
Alice wake.
Alice woke me up.
Welcome to Bright Falls.
Wow, wow, this place is nice.
So pretty.
These spaces are updated and still look crazy.
I didn't research if the remaster was any good or not, so...
Fingies crossed, I suppose.
Oh, we're too late now, maybe.
The facial animations in this game were always a little
goofy.
mocap that's my favorite though perfect haunting game you
know much about scp also gonna get concert tickets streaming
it is it is thank you though let's act like we're on
vacation oh my god go stand next to that old gentleman there
i want a shot of you with the town in the background you
you're gonna take sure i'll even give you a title for the
shot a city boy moments before he got eaten by a bear we're
gonna just go stand by a random man we don't know to take a
picture hi hello there you picked a good time to visit our
town how do I pose just two weeks away dear fast huh did you
hear that honey I'm posing wait can I jump you have a lovely
wife if you don't mind me saying I'm Pat Maine by the way
nice to meet you yeah I'm Ellen Wake I won't pretend I don't
recognize a famous writer such as yourself mr.
Wake a pleasure I'm an Oh, wow.
Oh, wow.
I hope this isn't too presumptuous of me, but I'm the night
host at the local radio station.
Any chance I could get an interview.
Wow.
Look, Mr. Maine, I'm on vacation.
In fact, I'd appreciate it if we could keep my being here
just between the two of us.
I'm sure you understand.
Fair enough.
You can trust me to be this.
I don't know.
Old people are never discreet.
How hard are you to track down if you change your mind,
though?
I hope you two have a lovely holiday.
Where is he looking?
I wanted to jump and like get some good poses.
She took a lot of photos of me talking to that guy.
Very nice.
I got a couple of really good ones.
And I see you made a friend.
That's cute.
We're going to the Bright Falls Deerfest, everybody.
Yeah.
Hey, bestseller.
How's my favorite writer?
Are you there yet?
Very.
Yeah.
We just got him.
Are the locals giving you trouble?
Just say the word and I'll hop on a plane.
Washington.
Make sure that you're left alone, Al.
No, Barry, we're fine.
Al, um, please call me by my full name, Alan Wake.
So, how is the place?
Has it gotten you?
Best character, really?
Barry, we're just settling in.
Barry.
Barry bugging me.
And you call me if there's a problem, okay?
Okay.
For you, buddy.
Talk to you later.
I love you too, Barry.
Ah, I love you, Barry.
You know he's going to be calling you every five minutes.
Barry is Barry.
I can always turn off the phone.
Barry is a bug.
Text message from Barry.
He says hi to you too.
Watery Bright Falls ferry line departures every hour.
Come on, let's get back to the car.
Ferry traffic.
I want to ride one of these.
What is this?
Guys.
Damn yuppies.
What's a yuppie?
Talking to me?
Bright Falls is pretty much Twin Peaks and Washington State
has some beautiful scenes when the shadow monsters ain't
trying to eat you.
City boy.
Okay.
Good day to you too.
Sure.
Whoa, look at the deer!
Whoa!
We're on the deer fest.
You get the full service here.
I've made all the arrangements.
I drive the car.
I'll even carry the bags.
All you have to do is drag your cute butt into the car and
enjoy the ride.
I have a passenger princess.
husband yeah but I guess 80s equivalent of a tech bro okay
well what are we going to drive Alice into the water I think
we need to dock first hold on I'm exploring a little bit
what's up here I want to see the view I want to see the
whole whoa if this is Washington that's That must be Mount
Rainier.
Let's get back in the car and drive to the town.
You're my best view.
Me.
That place is on fire.
Oh my god.
We just got here.
The ferry's about to reach the pier.
Let's get back in the car.
I think we have a few seconds.
Oh man.
Oh my gosh.
On the other side, I thought that was good.
Goku.
Alright, honey.
Let's check out Bright Falls.
Get in the car.
Let's go.
Do you see him?
But he looks just like Goku.
He looks just like Goku standing there.
Oh my god.
You see that guy in the orange jumpsuit?
need the red circle it's right there the the the life pres
pres from our preserver
okay i'm done exploring i'm being good we need to stop at
the local diner to get the cabin key from the landlord a mr
carl stucky he's waiting for us let's go fight somewhere
with the key i'll keep you up here and say 15 minutes sure
okay john Thank you so much for the 50 gift.
Alan, holy moly.
Thank you for coming here with me.
I love you too.
Go on.
I promise to behave.
He, like, interrupted her.
Thank you for coming here with me.
I love you too.
I've forgotten there were still places like this.
Towns where everybody knew everybody.
Welcome to the Odeer Diner.
Oh, dear Diner is so cute.
I'm looking for...
Alan Wake.
Oh, God.
I am your biggest fan.
I know people say that all the time, but I...
really am i'm glad to hear that rose rose i'm looking for mr
stucky carl stucky carl of course mr wake he must have gone
to visit the restroom he'll be back in a moment rose oh was
that stephen king believe it i've got all your books yeah i
got the cut out from the bookstore when they took it out of
the window yeah and you keep it here well okay good for you
good for you good what are these try the coffee just don't
blame me when you fall in love because it'll break your
heart when you have to leave oh nothing but black coffee
under a thin layer of skin that no that makes two of us no
longer human i don't know how i feel about someone calling
me that are you staying long mr wake i can't believe it i'm
having a conversation with alan wake who are you they just
this game you don't even have to prompt anything are you on
your own or is your wife with you exam show you the town if
you want i get off work at night right so much for quiet
vacation thanks rose we'll be sure to keep that in mind they
just talk yeah what kind of conversation is this i'm sure
that's wait down there looks pretty spooky let's go around
the other side though i think i have to the sudden stop okay
it's pretty handsome guy looks like he could be the the
billionaire ceo in one of those is that solidus he could be
the billionaire ceo in one of those um what's the word uh
like vertical uh swipe type short shows wait we got the
headband too do me a favor sonny i could really use a tune
right now Coconut number six in the jukebox.
I'd do it myself, but both of my legs have gone to sleep.
Bad circulation.
She's like you and your solid snake cut out.
You're right.
You disgust me.
Call yourself a rocker.
What's wrong with coconut?
Oh my god, it's solid snake and big boss enjoying apple
juice together.
Drink them both up just because we're brothers.
I don't think I won't murder you in your sleep Wait a
second.
I mean, they wouldn't be Yes, that's my favorite tune
Coconut All right, coconut Shut your mouth, you demented has
been If I had my hammer, I'd shut it for you If the eye
patch were on the other side, it would definitely be solid
as to give it a good shard whack a whack okay use it whack
it yeah and huh oh nice now that's what i'm talking about
this is coffee this is good isn't it this is where they went
after mgs4
wait this is gonna give me copyright struck like they're so
funny though this is so unserious Lime in the coconut, you
drink it all up.
Hey, why is it I could pick up the coffee thermos all the
way over here?
But literally when I was on top of it earlier, it wouldn't
let me.
Will they let me because I'm a famous?
No.
Audio jungle, audio jungle.
What's going on over here?
Who are you?
You good?
Don't go in there, young man.
You can hurt yourself in the dark.
I think I can handle it, ma'am.
I didn't want to wait.
I wanted to find Stucky.
To get the key and get out as soon as possible.
The waitress was giving me a headache.
Overheaker fans always did.
Wait, what do you mean die?
Why am I gonna die in here?
It's just a bathroom, no?
Wait, it's really dark.
Mr. Stucky?
I'm Stucky?
It's probably fine.
women's bathroom glad I can't go in there um why are you
guys smiling hello oh it's the men's bathroom Mr Stucky Mr
Stucky are you Stucky in the bathroom Carl couldn't make it
unfortunately he was taken ill but I have the key for you
and instructions on how to get to the lake okay I wish you a
good stay in my cabin I'll come by later to check how you've
settled in why is she just for a funeral and to meet your
wife How'd you know my mom on my wife?
I insist.
Oh Thanks are you gonna hit on her?
She's happily married.
She called my but cute actually Leave the diner Cauldron
lake is a special place very inspiring Yeah Not creepy at
all right Okay, there's still people back here, so...
You got lucky this time, young man.
You can hurt yourself in the dark.
This really ought to be fixed.
And then I must remind Sarah to change the lights of the
station that's been too long already.
I think I'm going to become... if I ever...
Well, I can't grow old because, you know, I'm...
Are they asleep?
Even that sounds better when you're singing.
Are you alright?
Can I turn this off?
Turn it off!
Audio jungle!
Everybody's talking to me!
Oh my god!
We're waiting for Dr. Hartman to come pick them up.
They wandered off from his clinic at the Calvin Lake Lodge.
Oh!
Really awesome.
Oh, is that my wife?
My hot wife?
Goodbye!
I'll be heading back to work as soon as Dr. Hartman gets
here, Rose.
Oh, but I'm not looking forward to the poison we have at the
Park Cafe.
I'm famous.
I know, but only she knows who I am.
This is what coffee should taste.
Well, what I was saying was about if I, you know, were to
ever grow old, but I'm a ghost, so I'm forever 19.
But if I were to ever grow old, I think I would be like that
lady.
I'm so scared of the dark.
I think I would also...
wake the dearest dear thank you thank you mission
accomplished the key and the directions my hero i got some
flashlights just in case oh no i mean good but oh wait who's
that hey wait mrs wake you're your keys wait where are we
going then
nut house oh I guess the the directions that she gave would
you believe this place oh this would make a wonderful
setting for a book we're supposed to be on vacation Alice
I'll figure it out when we get back okay okay we can talk
about this later no way that the creepy old lady I didn't
want to talk about it I wanted to bury my head in sand
there's another one of my favorites to go with Once upon a
time, I was a successful writer, but that was a long time
ago.
I hadn't been able to write a word in two years, not since
my last book.
That's not that long, though.
Right?
I mean, I don't think anybody's expecting a writer to put
out a book a year or anything, right?
Like, I thought he was going to say, like, 10 years.
It gets pretty dark out here, but they'll light your way.
Is this going to give me DMCA?
I give up already.
Mint Stucky, don't worry, step bro.
Wait, this place is so nice.
A diver's aisle.
I almost said...
Don't worry, honey.
I'll get you inside safe and sound before it gets dark.
And I've got the flashlight.
I know.
I'm okay.
Alice had a phobia.
The fear of darkness.
Me too.
I wanted to make sure we were inside with the lights on
before Sunday.
Oh my god everybody's afraid of the dark.
I relate to everybody.
Oh well, spooky.
Any long-haired maidens in there?
Well, well.
Well.
Now this place is nice, but it's kind of spooky that there's
like no one around here, no?
What about the deer festival?
Bird leg cabin.
Bird legs.
There's birds everywhere.
Birds cabin.
Birds took over the cabin.
What was...
Okay, a basement.
Music is so somber.
I'm just checking it out.
Seeing what we got around here.
There's so many birds!
the island had once been the site for a love story maybe it
would be that again maybe I hadn't written a word in two
years brother people still like G R R Martin and look at him
nothing for 15 years I know right isn't Game of Thrones
technically still not finished what was this it reminds me
of how what was it there was that one author an old
generator had been connected to the power cable there was
that one author that didn't write it was like a manga car he
didn't write anything for his manga because he was too busy
playing idol master or something oh oh yeah let there be
light i think i went out of order but that's okay okay
i'll freshen up a bit and start settling in okay mute up
around a bit sure thing was that him have fun Oh, oh.
I didn't get to look inside that.
It was a beautiful place.
I told myself I could rest here.
Sleep here.
And forget about my work.
Well, he did pass away, didn't he?
Oh, my gosh.
I forgot about that.
I thought we could be happy here.
Return to Alice.
Okay.
Return to my beautiful wife.
Alice.
Alice, my wife.
Don't touch the windows.
We don't know how often this place is clean.
Uh-oh.
Spooky music's starting.
Alice?
Honey?
You mean our wife?
Alice takes off her shoes.
Um, hello, Mr. Stomping around in the mud out there.
Have some tact, please.
Ah!
A thermos.
I can't believe I missed that one.
I'm so...
Alan, I'm upstairs.
I have a surprise for you.
Didn't she say consider this our honeymoon?
Let's turn that off because it's scary.
Wait, let's turn on.
No, turn off.
Turn off the creepy radio.
Oh.
Just ran into one on the ferry.
Famous artist, no less.
Oh.
We'll see if we can rope him into an interview later on.
Excuse you?
Keep me on the DL!
Hi, Pat.
It's Rose.
Oh, my God.
Oh, no.
What's on your mind?
I know who that famous artist was.
It was Alan Wake.
Rose, you snitch!
Well, Rose, I...
I just saw him at the diner.
Oh, I am so excited.
He's here.
I'm sure he's glad to be here, too.
Well, folks, I guess the secret's out.
This is Pat Main.
I'm KBFFM.
And now it's the music.
Great.
So much for keeping a low profile.
Oh, my God.
Can't turn it off.
No?
Ha ha ha!
Yeah!
Way to go, Rose.
Oh my gosh.
Never trust a Rose in a video game, huh?
Alan!
Come here, slow poke.
I'm waiting.
Oh god, we can't keep a maiden waiting now, Kemp.
That's some great visual storytelling now, isn't it, folks?
Well, hello there.
I'm not the surprise.
It's in the study.
Oh, what?
What do you mean?
Okay.
No, come on.
You're my wife.
And you're dressed like that.
Oh, we're in the 70s.
Oh, okay.
Hey, but...
Come on.
You can't say you're not the surprise when you're like that
in front of me.
Oh, my God.
Surprise.
Alice what is this I guess I have a small confession to make
I thought maybe you could write here that a change of
scenery would get you damn Alice you everyone hey hey hey
just hear me out there's a local doctor dr. Hartman I read a
book of his he has a private clinic here he specializes in
helping artists so now you want to get me committed no it's
not like that that's not well Alan Alan I don't want to hear
it.
God damn it, Alice.
Wait, what?
Wait, did he not notice that the lights turned off for a
second?
I knew she wouldn't follow me in the dark.
I needed some time alone to think things through.
Wait, what do you mean?
That's so messed up, though.
I mean, I don't blame him for being upset.
I think that's kind of, you know.
Damn it.
Alice?
Alice!
The cabin had gone dark.
All the lights were out.
Oh my god.
Where are you?
I'm coming!
It's actually quite bright up here, no?
Oh my god!
I'm coming!
What the hell?
Alice!
Help me!
Oh my god!
Her screams are...
Oh, uh...
Oh, no.
Wait, that's like...
Oh, no!
Did she hit the rocks on the way down?
Wait, did he hit the rocks on the way down?
Oh, no.
Keep going, Alice.
Wake up.
Alice?
Oh, no.
This is like the opposite.
Opposite of games usually where they tell you to stop
playing the game.
She tells you to keep going.
I couldn't remember how I got there.
All I knew was that something terrible had happened to
Alice.
The phone was dead.
I'd have to find help on foot.
Why did we get in the car?
This is part of the dream?
We're back in Dream World?
Among Alice's things was...
a book the creator's dilemma by a dr. Emil Hartman I mean oh
no I didn't like it and I didn't like the guy's smug face on
the cover either oh no is this gonna be like what is what's
real wait where's my flashlight and my guns okay I have
nothing right now that's fine things are everything is OSP
so it's have a phone i could use it looked like a long hike
through the forest to get there
baby core thank you for the gift dude thank you so much wait
so we don't know so what is oh we do not know what is real
what's a dream right now damn there goes the micah okay oh
my god is alice actually dead
Is this- this isn't like a we kill my wife kind of games, is
it?
And I'm stuck in a nightmare because of it, is it?
What's- Oh, the focus is kind of fun.
Saracho, welcome to the membership.
Thank you, welcome back.
Hello?
Oh, the light!
Oh my gosh, it reminds me of the thing.
Like the cover for the thing.
That's Silent Hill.
I know, I'm just- Well, a lot of games do it now.
Someone there?
what's it say what is it the loose sheets of paper were
pages from a manuscript entitled departure that was the name
i planned to use for the next novel i had never gotten
started i was named the author i hadn't written it i
couldn't remember writing it in the scene on the page the
hero was attacked by an axe murderer in the woods at night
wait i don't like that um all fiction you found manuscript
pages you can access them with the wait i have to make sure
I press the right one.
Is it this button?
This button.
Wake attacked by a shadowy murderer.
What did... What does that mean?
The little symbol.
Oh, find this page in nightmare difficulty mode.
The man turned to face me.
His face was covered in shadows.
It was hard to make him out in the darkness of the forest
that surrounded us.
But the axe he lifted was plain to see.
It glistened with the blood of his victim.
He grinned madly.
The shadows were were alive distorting his features it was a
scene from a nightmare but I was awake I was a wake Alan
period wake this doesn't sound good oh wait hold on I want
to what's the title page departure by Alan wake oh that's it
it's literally it okay
um is this okay I think this is the right way
Surely that was...
Aw, man!
I was about to say, surely that was...
That won't happen again.
I don't have a gun!
Queue emotional outburst.
Oh no!
There's light over there.
Checkpoint reached.
There's a lot of checkpoints in this game.
It's actually quite forgiving, which is very nice.
The lights up ahead were a good sign.
Maybe I wouldn't have to hike all the way down to the gas
station to find a phone.
Narration of this game is great.
Also, I want to do a little bit smaller for the subtitles.
You're walking in the woods.
There's no one around and your phone is dead.
Out of the corner of your eye, you spot him.
Shia Laboff.
Alan is a good rider.
You'll see Mint, the best at riding.
I believe you?
Tentative.
Wait, climb in the tree, baby.
Nice.
Anybody there?
Please, I've been in an accident.
My name is Alan Wake.
I am a writer.
I am seeking assistance.
I have been in an accident.
Oh.
You got this?
I can't tell what the yellow dot is though still.
Is that like where I'm supposed to...
It's not where I'm supposed to be.
Is this where I'm supposed?
Oh, it's just, like, it's the marker that says find help,
but...
Hey!
Hey, you!
Okay.
There's been an accident.
I need help.
This is it.
I need to...
It's got the spooky...
Cabins for rent in...
Lightfall!
Oh, hell.
Carl Stucky.
Oh, no!
To beat you.
No, Carl!
Non-refundable reservation deposit required.
Fair and square.
Oh!
Uh-oh.
Where is he?
Oh, gosh.
This is like a maze in here.
Where did I go?
Oh, that's a flashlight right there.
Ah!
Where did he come from?
Oh, he's scaring me.
This is so scary.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, thermos.
Can I get a gun?
Or a flashlight or anything?
Non!
refundable i'm carl ouch oh my god holy cow i'm just gonna
book it to arrive you really lose my god here's stucky out
of this any second now and stucky would be knocking on the
door with his axe like Nicholson in the Shining.
Oh my gosh, yeah, revolver.
Flashlight!
We're back in business, baby.
Batteries.
Give me batteries.
Give me more batteries.
Very nice.
Carl Stucky.
During your pastoral hackling.
Trying not walking.
It's a background audio cutting off repeat for anyone else.
In It's not for me.
Testably.
Proven.
Health benefits.
Like you.
You.
Yes.
Right fall sheriff station.
Oh, may I...
And keep those...
No!
Oh, my God.
Oh, no.
Holy cow.
Oh, shoot.
It's...
Ah!
Oh my god.
Uh, I can't move.
There we go.
Get out of there!
Okay.
Um, where do I go?
Not over here, I guess.
Where did the tractor go?
Okay.
Very cool.
Where do I go?
Oh, thank you.
There were more of them.
More of who?
Ouch, ouch.
Oh,
my God.
It's tricky.
I'm trying to learn the combat a little bit.
Because my hand keeps slipping between L1 and, like,
trigger.
You know?
The bulldozer had gone over the cliff with the office.
I hope Stucky had suffered the same fate.
But I wasn't planning on staying to find out.
Damn.
I'm guessing I have to fight them, though, because...
Well, I...
I guess I just need to turn off the power to...
And then it's XXXXX reload, right?
Okay, yeah.
But, okay.
Shield first, then shoot.
Yeah, like, okay, so it's...
No.
Shoot, okay, yeah, okay.
Lensflare is their shield HP.
What's that mean?
I didn't see a lens flare.
Okay.
Oh, okay, I think I...
You.
Woo!
Nice!
Nice you?
Oh, can I...
Oh, shoot.
Ouch, ouch!
I got too far and...
I'd never fired a gun outside of getting used to it getting
used to it I just killed someone or something there were no
bodies they just disappeared okay if I was dreaming it felt
real enough to make me sick all right getting used to it I
love the yellow paint let's go I love how he narrates
everything it's so good kick it don't shoot until they flash
the darkness makes the immune to bullets oh okay the dark
forest was the last place I wanted to go but I had no choice
I had to get to the gas station what's the yellow paint for
though it only shows up when I wait what's the yellow paint
for this way Erie hand-painted graffiti was revealed by my
flashlight someone had hidden a chest of supplies near it oh
neat oh
Anything else?
That's it?
Alright, let's go.
The breathing is creepy.
Is this the kind of game where I can, like...
I mean, obviously in this one, I...
I guess I could have avoided the combat if I just ran past
them and kicked the thing, but...
Halo, when the flashlight is on them, is the shield.
Maybe I'm just not seeing it.
Sorry, I'll stop breathing.
Woo!
Combat is mostly unavoidable.
Okay, okay.
Good to know.
Yay, checkpoint!
Rabbit season.
So like...
Oh!
Like that.
But then how do I...
No, he's...
Oh!
Like that!
Wabbit season.
Understood.
What's up here?
More people?
It's like a little light.
What's a little light for?
Oh, magic script.
Not survival horror nerd here.
No, Alan Wake is not survival horror.
It's way easier to take the enemies out than to run away.
Okay, good.
Hi, hi, Minto.
Hi, hi, Brendan.
Hope you're feeling good today.
Oh, read the pages.
So true.
Rose daydreams about Wake.
Wait, Wake fights a Taken with life.
The Taken stood before me.
It was impossible to focus on it as if it stood in a blind
spot caused by a brain tumor and eye disease.
It was bleeding shadows like ink underwater, like a cloud of
blood from a shark bite.
i was terrified i squeezed the flashlight like my life
depended on it willing it to stop coming any closer suddenly
something gave and the light seemed to shine brighter magic
and then rose rose knew she had been gushing but right now
she didn't care gushing as far as she was concerned her
brief meeting with alan wake was literally the high point of
her life she watched as he got pretty confident at ease with
wake not like rose they were perfect for each other she'd
have given anything to be called their friend oh my god you
just met him at the at the cafe for two seconds ma'am watch
your head
checkpoint oh my god
what the hell was that your guess is as good as mine Spooky
happenings are happening ahead.
When I saw the river below, something uncoiled itself inside
my head.
I realized that I'd have to find a way across.
I didn't even want to look at the water.
Yes?
Yes.
I'm looking around for any secrets.
It's so jungly.
Things really boring in town for Rose, okay?
It's probably true, right?
Alright.
This is like really something, huh?
Is that a box there?
Like, that I couldn't?
Oh, come on, jump.
There we go.
Alan jump.
Alan run.
Alan explore.
Like, what the heck are these trees?
Well, it is a box.
Just a box.
Oh, it's a manuscript we're getting like the whole what's it
called like the whole story so far but in these pages barry
wheeler was bouncing off the walls he jumped on a plane
after his calls were ignored by both al and alice for
several days oh it could mean that they were both on a
second honeymoon but barry didn't buy it al had been way too
unstable for that not sleeping messed up oh no barry had
years of experience dealing with alan wake and he couldn't
ignore it something was wrong something was wrong so barry's
coming okay
oh i thought i heard something like manifesting like an evil
guy oh there was an evil guy oh
is that what's his name yeah stucky in the dark stalk me
rose is like us with our vtuberoshis we still want to be
considered a real friend no What is to be said by?
No!
Forgot how Max Pain, like Alan Wake, moved.
Same team?
We could play as Rose in expansion.
It's silly.
Wait, that sounds so fun.
That sounds pretty silly.
Stucky!
Oh, batteries.
And ammo.
Okay.
Oh.
The game?
Wow!
Oh!
What happened?
Wait.
Ah!
Okay.
The game suddenly turned into eternal darkness.
Oh my gosh.
That scared me.
I thought I was gonna have to restart or something.
Our sanity is too low, Hey, buddy.
Paragon, paragon.
Let's see.
Going around.
There's a big old light up there.
I guess it wants me to go over there.
I'm assuming.
The staircase was broken.
No!
I had to make my way up some other way.
Who turned out the light?
Okay, open that up.
Grab everything.
Hell you.
I like that it does kind of guide you, though.
I see where the, like, what the yellow dot means now.
Wait, what was that?
Oh, there was something else I missed.
Oh, I can't.
This isn't really happening!
Urm.
There was no power.
There was bound to be a generator somewhere at the logging
site.
You mean that green light that's flashing over there?
Psycho Mantis using blackout.
Oh, whoops.
Jump to climb.
Hmm.
I think...
What's climb?
What am I climb?
Oh, probably the staircase, yeah.
I think I gotta go over there.
Me thinks.
With all this forestry equipment around, there had to be
something I could use to reach the top.
Am I going to parkour?
What's going on here?
Okay.
There's a thermos.
I see it.
You guys see it right there.
It's right there.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, there's fall damage.
Today I learned.
Alan jump.
Alan, don't jump too far.
I'm not going to be such a stickler for the thermoses
because I don't want to that to be like the main focus but
if i see one i'll try and get it i might i've already missed
one so you know no biggie allen fall
trying to get trying to get better at this holy cow i forget
that i can like reload really quickly and a script page and
something else Shotgun!
Let's go!
What do we got here?
Wake attacked by birds!
Cut down entirely!
I gotta get better at dodging, but...
I heard them before I saw them.
Swooping down from the sky and screeching as they came.
I spun around just as the cloud was upon me.
For an instant, I stared into a hundred dead eyes.
Black pearls glittering in the darkness.
I raised the flashlight and the swarm exploded like
fireworks.
Oh, they did?
They were supposed to do that?
That is burned.
Turned into ash.
I couldn't hear my scream above theirs.
Ha!
What?
Okay.
It's kind of funny.
Crayon made!
Woohoo!
Thank you so much for the- for the- Forget the thank you!
Thank you.
Crayon.
You guys say crayon or crayon?
I've been trying the more to say crayon instead of crayon.
But it feels more natural to say crayon.
Crayon I like saying crayon There's light They
won't be able to touch me there right
Supposedly Allegedly
Crayon berries I know some people that say crown What What
second crayon berries i don't know i know it's crayon but i
just always said crayon
i say crown can i well how do you say how do you say crown
where do you get crown from
oh i'm moving it oh i'm going the wrong way
that should be good right Okay.
Yeah.
Lots of light now.
It shouldn't be around here.
Wee.
Alan, jump!
Oh my god.
Alan, don't fall!
Alan, what's that?
Alan, gas, gas, gas.
Alan, jump!
Hell yeah.
Alan, make it.
What's over here?
Gotta be something.
Besides target practice.
Alan Verb.
Might be my favorite joke ever.
Oh!
Um, what?
What was that?
Alan glitch!
Is there supposed to be something here?
Checkpoint!
I swear this game is more eternal darkness than we realize,
baby.
My sanity is crazy low.
What do we have?
Oh, that looks like shotgun shells, yeah.
Well, I was just outside for a breath of fresh air.
air and what a night i i know most of you are probably in
your beds by now but if you're still up and around take a
moment step outside for a spell and breathe in the weather
is absolutely still the sky is crystal clear it's like
before alan finish it off with gunderbolt epic version of
this game is riddled by these glitches well isn't epic the
only way you can play it technically or That's what I
thought I heard someone say before.
Right, here I am.
And we'll keep you company all night long if I weren't.
So bright.
It looks like I'm not the only one staying up late.
Caller, you're on the air.
Maurice Horton.
What are you up to?
Well, I was just taking Toby on his walkies.
Walkies.
Oh, isn't it beautiful out there?
Sure, but Pat, the reason I called is that Toby heard
something rustling in the undergrowth and took off after it,
and I couldn't find it.
Probably a rabbit.
I have it on Steam.
Oh, really?
Well, heck, I got it for free.
on this one so it's fine.
And Toby's a friendly dog.
Uh oh.
We're not gonna have to shoot Toby, are we?
We were pretty far
put.
Well, Maurice, it's out there now.
Hope Toby comes home soon.
Yeah, thanks, Pat.
You have a good night.
There's no urgency for this dog at all.
Not even like a...
This is what my dog looks like.
Yellow.
Are these ever a trap?
Oh,
I don't like the breathing at all.
It's so scary.
Breathing equals secrets nearby.
Oh, that's what it is.
It just sounds scary.
Oh my god, the music.
This game's out to get me.
Out to DMCA me.
What do we got?
What?
That's what I'm doing right now.
At first I kept finding the pages as if by accident.
The book I couldn't remember was either a terrible and true
prophecy or an act of creation that had rewritten the world.
I began to hunt the pages feverishly, for they held the
answer to the mystery.
With it, I could save myself.
Yes, it did.
I could save Alice.
We could?
Is that what we are thinking?
All right.
What's this?
Just some sticks.
Whoa.
sorry that's a brick or a boulder yeah on the road again the
gas station was closer now it's light welcoming in the
darkness the best dogs in the state belly burster is the
best with no comes lobster dog is second best the famous dog
is zoom the famous dog is Rush.
Stucky.
Don't scare me out here, okay?
Please.
I'm just a...
What's that sound?
Don't sound so good.
We... Safe haven.
Wait.
What do you mean, safe haven?
Wow!
Child, child.
If I turn this on?
Wait, don't pick up the revolver.
Ah!
Oh my god.
Ouch.
They're gonna get me good.
I didn't realize I had my flare equipped, but good thing I
did, I suppose.
Please start.
Oh my gosh.
Cute!
Thank you for the redirect.
Oh my gosh.
Now, yeah, now it's safe.
I'm starting Alan Wake for the first time we just started
not too long ago but things are already kind of corrosive
hey chaos thank you for the five gifted thank you for the
five gifted KFP bread thank you for the tech gifted thank
you for the gifted whipsy thank you for the five gifted
superliminal thank you for the five gifted well wait what
was Kiwawa doing what is your stream But to be fair, I
wasn't on my computer until like five minutes before I
started stream.
Pokemon Z-A.
Boy, are you kidding?
Well, thank you for the techie.
I'm just like, yo, yo, thank you for the podcast.
Simply thinking for the twine.
Wow, I'm playing Pokemon.
Back up to that Pokemon grind.
It looks really fun.
I thought about it.
Z-A.
Pokemon Z-A.
Z-Z-Z-Z-Z-Z-Z-Z-Z-Z-Z-Z-Z-Z-Z-Z-Z-Z-Z-Z-Z-Z-Z-Z-ZZZZZZ.
Play it!
Should I?
Oh, my PC just crashed as I was typing a comment.
I was saying.
Bill, thank you for the tech gifted.
Do it.
Pizza.
Why are we saying pizza?
Congratulations on your spicy adult only concert happening.
Why do you have to say that?
Why do you like that?
Why do you...
Why is a phrase like that?
Speedifier?
Thank you!
It trickles!
They did...
That was pretty funny, though.
They did have to change it at, like, the last second.
There's been so many...
Oh, man.
Can I rant a little bit?
Not about Oshi Spark, but, like...
Because they've been great.
Everything that has happened has been out of their hands,
unfortunately.
Basically, basically, last second, they were like, they
heard, so, they had the contract, and they made the contract
that said that the concert would be for all ages, but then
the people that went through the contract, they didn't
specify that the location was 21 plus only, so, so, um, what
the heck then they had to change at the very last minute to
be like sorry if you pre sailed for a ticket but if you're
under 21 you have to you can't you can't you should don't
get a ticket because you won't be allowed in so first there
was that and then unfortunately with the venue that we chose
we had to sell the tickets through Ticketmaster and luckily
I believe all the pre-sale tickets were bought by real
people because they were for everybody who registered you
know only yeah ticket master hey there Oshi Spark said
they're currently looking into if the because the general
sales opened up today and they're it's hard to say if they
were completely scalped or if um So if you see someone on
like, what's it called, Twitter being like, I have tickets
for Minto's jazz show, don't trust it because it could be a
scam, you know, something like that.
But Oshi Spark is looking into it.
So I apologize.
I know it's out of my hands, but I never thought that that
would happen to an event like mine.
So I'm really, really sorry.
into like Taylor Swift.
I guess there's probably people out there that are just
waiting to scalp any event on Ticketmaster, but yeah.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
Sadly, it is all concerts.
But, you know, there will be events in the future and they
will not use Ticketmaster.
that I can guarantee so yes yes yes that I can tell you
definitely a learning experience yeah well I was like
stressing about it before stream too I was just like I don't
want you know people to be upset it's not Oshi Spark's fault
mint as powerful as Taylor's Swift confirmed.
Oh, yeah.
Call me.
You're not a Swiftie.
You're a Minty.
But, oh.
It's not your fault, Min.
We understand the situation.
No.
Even scalpers.
They don't.
No.
They don't know.
They just buy up any tickets that's on there.
You'd think that we would have, like, things to help prevent
this by now.
But clearly, it's an issue.
Clearly, it's too difficult to figure out, I suppose.
But, yeah, sorry, I just wanted to rant a little bit about
it.
Oshi Spark has been great.
They have not.
They have been very communicative.
And anytime I have a question or anything or an issue, they
have been good about helping me out.
So, I just signed an NFL contract if you want to go on a
date sometime.
Wait, what's this?
Taylor Swift song um players gonna play play play play play
play but I'm just gonna wake wake wake wake wake Alan wake
Alan wake okay shall we continue was this a checkpoint
checkpoint I don't know actually where are we going wait
it's telling me to go this way
Is there an evil guy out there?
Another one?
I can't tell if it's evil guy or ambiance.
Evil guys!
I
have to catch the vibe because I'm at work again tonight.
Good luck with work, Phil!
Uh, uh...
Oh, let's go.
Oh, shoot.
Wait.
Oh
my god, I didn't expect it to be right there!
Oh, scared me, man.
Holy cow!
I tried to switch to my flare.
Okay, it's the left, lefty pod.
Manuscript.
TV in the gas station.
I stepped into the gas station's garage.
It was dark and quiet.
The place was a mess.
Oh.
It looked like someone trashed the place or that there'd
been some kind of fight Light spilled into the room through
an open door at the back and I made my way toward it
Spoilers nice shooting text.
I was blinded by a bright light An old portable TV on the
shelf had come alive by itself Impossibly I could see myself
on the screen talking like a madman The game is spoiling me.
Maybe I should have Ready So we're going around up and
around around, it seems.
Oh, thank goodness light.
It gets so bright.
Can I pick up that?
Pick up that.
Is there anything over there?
Oh, this is where I'm supposed to go.
Wait, can I not go this way?
Oh, it's a cliff.
For some reason, I thought it was a bridge.
Oh, okay, I see it.
It's right over there.
This is, like, the largest lumberyard ever.
Why is that swinging down there?
Am I about to play American Warrior?
American Ninja Warrior?
What's going on?
Alan flip.
Alan, do a flip.
I hear.
Breath.
Breathe.
Spooky breath.
Spooky breathe.
Oh my god!
The quietest boulders ever.
Alan breathe, Alan breathe.
Yeah.
I'll take another flare gun, yeah.
Just pick them up, pick all of them up.
Very nice!
Alan parkour.
So, I have to ask though, how many episodes are in this
game?
I wonder if we should do it kind of similarly to where I've
done in the past where I do one episode.
episode per stream?
John Allen Wake!
Six episodes, five episodes?
They aren't all the same length.
Ah, okay, okay.
I guess we'll have to see.
Six plus DLCs.
Oh, I see, I see.
Salads aren't bad for you though.
It's okay.
You can touch a salad.
It's just lettuce.
Logging area.
Okay.
We back in the lumber mines.
It doesn't work.
I give up.
Is that a page down there?
Ambush!
Holy moly.
That's a lot of guys.
Yeah, you saw it.
You really thought, huh?
Alan cracked?
That was pretty good, wasn't it?
That was pretty clean.
If I'd just say so myself?
Should probably use my shotgun more often, huh?
Yeah, science!
Oh my god, it really is the Twilight Zone.
Hustleop would be proud.
Don't say that!
Night Springs.
Tonight's episode.
A quantum suicide.
Wait, can we watch the whole thing?
If our lives are already written, it would take a courageous
man to change the script.
Having called a press conference, Barclay Colvin is about to
demonstrate that very courage.
How long is it?
Let's hurry up.
Ladies and gentlemen of the press, I am Dr. Barclay Colvin.
And I'm glad so many of you could join me here at the
Moorcock Institute.
Tonight, I'm going to give a practical demonstration of the
many worlds interpretation.
Whoa.
As you can see, this is a loaded 9mm pistol.
it shall be part of a thought experiment and now oh a real
experiment i didn't even know as a quantum suicide did he
say suicide is that a real gun he's kidding right please
please stay welcome to membership thank you there is no risk
observe what occurs when i place the weapon against my own
the more what institute now you might think this round is
merely a dud the dud not so flower pot and yet I myself
cannot be harmed with this gun with each pull of the trigger
two new realities branch off one in which the weapon didn't
fire and one where it did with my machine here I have
ensured that this reality that's crazy I have bestowed upon
myself quantum immortality this gun kill me uh-oh so wait
wait wait what you're saying is foreshadowing trigger in
another reality you die yes yes of course but that's
completely trivial there's an infinite number of things that
could happen at any moment they always do happen somewhere
the point is this one thing oh my god not happen here insane
insane insane hey was this thing supposed to be plugged in i
stumbled on it you fools gaze upon quantum immortality oh my
god the reactions are crazy poor dr colvin filled by his own
hubris or the ignorance of the masses oh my god the the
narrator voice is so perfect Adam unobserved curiosity often
kills the cat the camera was set up by a spring ah it sounds
just like the Twilight Zone narrator it's so good it's so
good just a box just a box just about I like how everything
has like slight ragdoll physics it's really funny okay i
feel like i'm about to face off against a boss potentially
so let's get our maybe our shoddy wait before we do that
before we open this gate though
we shall get this page
wait lies to the sheriff wait a second wait a second you're
You're already making me as a criminal!
Wait, wait, wait, wait!
Wait, wait, wait!
Remedy loves doing these show things.
That's so fun!
I love that.
Alright, let's press the button.
Why am I- what am I lying for?
What do I need to lie about?
Am I breaking and entering?
Is that what I'm lying about?
Turn off.
It's quite loud in here.
I mean to have a great day!
Wait, great day!
Sorry, I was saying...
In my brain, I was saying Quinn!
Have a great day!
Oh, good checkpoint.
Okay.
Oh, that's a lot.
Oh, no.
Okay.
Spooky.
All right.
I guess we're going up against him now.
Hi, Shuts!
I'm scared!
It came from, like, my left ear.
But I guess it doesn't matter.
It's probably play, like, some sort of cinematic, I imagine.
Oh!
Yep.
Ha!
Oh, shoot!
There's a bunch of them.
Oh shoot, there's a bunch of them.
Oh shoot, wow, that was so close.
Nice.
Oh god, there was so many.
Whoa, what the heck was that?
Oh, oh.
Oh.
Is he...
Did he...
Okay, nice.
Oh, oh.
Oh.
He's kind of freaky.
Woo!
Ah!
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
I tried to...
Oh.
Is it just him left?
I guess so.
I don't know where he went.
Oh, there he is.
Oh, my God.
Nice!
Okay.
Stucky's body vanished.
Leaving behind only a lifetime of nightmares to come.
Assuming I'd reach the lights of the gas station alive.
Um, I'm gonna go back to this.
I don't want to waste all my shotgun ammo.
I feel like I did.
But whatever.
Uh, where am I going?
This...
This... There's a green light here, though.
Do I not need to... Oh, Tharbois.
Oh, I do need to go this way.
Just kidding.
Anything else around here, though?
Just doing a little bit of exploration.
Doesn't pay.
I mean, it doesn't hurt to be curious.
The massive dumpster of ammo.
I know it's so great.
Honestly, just... I feel like I should stick to my revolver.
because it's it has they give you so much ammo wait hello
for now yeah I guess I guess that's true they're like hey
they're at the beginning of the game your little baby
recognize the parade float I had seen in Bright Falls when I
first arrived I did see that I did I did see that what was
that was a spooky sound don't like there anything in here no
okay
I'm hearing such a spooky noise something's creaking after
the insanity I just experienced in the darkness the lights
of the gas station felt comforting at least for a moment the
same world reasserted itself
My manuscript.
I guess we'll read the pages after.
I don't want to get...
I don't know.
What is like...
Well, I guess there's no proper way to play it.
But like, what is like the...
What do people prefer?
Do you prefer that I read it and get kind of spoiled?
Or do you prefer that I wait until the full episode's done?
The point is to read them immediately.
Oh, okay, okay.
Then let's do that.
The cabin on Cauldron Lake, she asked.
looked at me suspiciously the early morning light flooded
through the office windows I would probably never have
gotten out of the woods alive without her help but I
couldn't tell her the truth of what I'd face the previous
night she think I was lying or crazy she'd lock me up I mean
he wrote and she wouldn't help me find Alice I guess that's
fair well you know I don't know Stucky spat on the garage
floor and tried to shake the cobwebs from his head ever
since the couple never showed to pick up the keys things had
been fuzzy something a feeling caught his attention.
Stucky looked up and stared as his brain tried in vain to
process the horror before him.
He stumbled back, knocking over a can of oil.
A black pool spread across the floor while he struggled for
a brief moment, then let go as the unrelenting darkness
engulfed him.
Oh no, he got like possessed.
So we got all of them, minus the things that are for
nightmare mode only, so that's cool.
the deer fest had been two weeks away when we arrived if the
day count on the banner was right i was missing a whole week
between the night we got here and now the game heard about
mince smile anti-spoiler method it went bad right what am i
focusing on okay i'm just looking around a bit oh they're
almost hmm
So we're about to meet the cop, I guess?
We did say that we would...
That we go into the gas station and we read the...
Or we watch the TV and it's freaky.
The garage was a mess.
It looked like someone had trashed the place.
Or that there'd been some kind of fight.
Yeah, yeah, that's what we read in the...
In the...
What's it called?
The note.
In the manuscript.
I'm so sorry.
It's not a note.
It's much more intelligent than that.
I'll keep writing.
outside there's only darkness outside the cabin outside the
story there's only darkness I can feel a presence in the
dark just now I can smell the perfume in the room I'll reach
her I'll fix it up I'll bring her back the story will come
true if I stop she's lost I don't believe this it'd been me
on the TV talking crazy was I losing my mind oh buddy things
are not going so hot for you keep that's a thing but it's
not i thought that sign did not say welcome i thought it
just said women i was like yeah okay oh my gosh one thing i
really want to do is i want to go to uh to washington so i
could go see the orcas i want to go orca watching orca are
you here yeah
women am i right cheese and cream big stuffer oh yeah what's
this oh the 68th annual deer they were so close so true
september 15th to 18th games and activities raffle tickets
fishing competition pie contest i mentioned before New
Year's does I wanted a pumpkin pie you know and I went and
got pumpkin pie and one thing that also shocked me was how
many places were open on New Year's I thought the grocery
store would definitely be closed but it was open and I got
me a pumpkin pie yeah live music oh surprise competition For
the children, Bucktooth Charlie, Afternoons.
Okay, and Montgomery, the Mystic's Amazing Phantasmagoria.
Evenings.
I'm very curious what Bucktooth Charlie could be.
That's the whole...
That's the whole act.
Phantasmagoria, what is this?
Toho, I totally thought the same thing.
Don't miss the legendary...
Dear Fest Parade!
Oh, am I reading?
Oh, I'm reading this.
I thought I was reading the candy.
I was like...
Oh, my God.
Bigfoot.
Cow feet.
We sell propane and propane accessories.
All right, let's use the phone.
Hello.
Excuse me, ma'am.
Uh-oh.
Rifle, sheriff station.
Oh, I thought I heard.
Oh, wait.
The cops actually...
came holy moly oh
thank god sheriff sheriff sarah breaker you are i'm alan
wake but listen i was in a car crash my wife alice she's
missing calm down mr wake we were staying in a cabin on the
island on cauldron lake there's no island on cauldron lake
not since the big eruption in the 70s what please i can take
you there okay you look like you've taken a pretty bad knock
to the head Uh-oh, the concussion.
I'm concussed.
Listen, we'll figure this out.
Please get in the car.
We'll swing by the lake and then we'll go to the station,
okay?
Don't fall asleep.
Have you seen Stucky, the guy who owns this place?
I realized I couldn't tell her what had happened in the
forest.
She wouldn't have believed me.
And then she wouldn't have helped me with Alice.
That's why we lie.
That's why we're a big old liar.
Yeah, I murdered him out in the lumberyard.
Wait, there's no island?
Oh.
Look.
Alan lies.
Oh, my.
Wow, steamy.
That'd be a great onsen.
Oh.
A candy-colored clown.
Tiptoes to my room every night.
And just to sprinkle star dust and End of episode one!
Woo!
Everything is all right.
I close my eyes.
You are so DMC-ed.
That's fine.
At this point, I can't stop it.
Alan jingle.
Alan jungle.
Audio jungle.
Audio jingle.
Wait, is there no like...
This is it.
It was just the...
the music how's the game so far it's so great on alan wake
sorry i skipped this one i came to bright falls with my wife
alice thank you for coming here with me i thought maybe you
could write here why did the wives always go missing now
she's missing sorry i walk you behind the wheel of a crashed
car i'm missing a week i was attacked by shadowy men
me to the lake alice and i had stayed at alice missing but
the cabin had disappeared
taken episode two wait new york city three years ago
helen house dad oh honey i'm home back here sweetie how was
it worst weather i've ever seen oh my god it's raining
sideways it'll warm you up okay switch on the coffee man
Well, I know we're on episode two, but it's only been two
hours.
Are you guys okay with me ending it a little early today?
I do have another stream on the Densetsu channel, where it
will be Densetsu versus Beasties.
So, I think because I've been going a little bit with longer
streams, we'll take it easy today.
We'll end it here.
Maybe next time we can get through two and a half hours.
three episodes two and three depending on how long they are
so yeah wait oh sorry i took control with my mouse
liberatoraxia oh my gosh it's been forever welcome back to
eq one second one second care guys careful guys mint has a
particular set of skills my skills my skills more plug for
Minto visiting Washington someday.
Yeah, should I visit Washington?
Should I?
Let's move.
I'm gonna shooom.
And we're gonna boom.
And I'm gonna one second.
I'm gonna clean up a little bit.
Let's see.
We're here at my desk and my giant coffee.
everybody my giant coffee let's put on some music amazing
music that was so fun I it did spook me a little bit but I
think because it's not survival horror I feel more what's
the word more inclined to attack I'm like okay I'm here to
fight baby it's action horror for sure yeah yeah yeah the
resources are there for you yeah there were resources all
the time i'm sure it will get less and less but um it was
pretty cool i love that it's very twin peaks okay i'll be
honest i've never watched twin peaks before it's definitely
probably breaking bad is like a series that i would like to
watch i know about it but you know But it's also, like, I
mean, very obviously Twin Peaks inspired and Twilight Zone
inspired and...
Yeah!
On nightmare mode, it's very rough.
I believe that.
I'm so curious what the notes say, though, that are...
I feel kind of like... I'm like, hey, wait a second.
Um, why is it...
Why?
Why... I should be able to read those notes if I want to.
I should be able... There should be a way...
Like, if I want to get the notes, I have to do a special
challenge, but...
I don't know.
Thank you for checking out episode 1!
If you enjoyed how silly the game is, I promise it only gets
dumber and sillier each episode.
Let's go!
The notes are kind of spoilers.
You're meant to beat the game first.
Oh, the one's a nightmare.
Isn't Twin Peaks a booby bar?
Has anybody ever been to the booby bar, Twin Peaks?
You mean manuscripts?
Oh, yes, the manuscripts.
When we were in Orlando, there was, there was like, I had a
goal.
I had a goal because the previous time that I went to
Orlando, Florida, I tried to go to Hooters with some
friends.
I'm sorry, my wife.
I was busy in here, wretching in a car.
What?
Orgar, are you okay?
I hope you're just car sick.
I hope you feel better.
Oh my gosh.
But there was, I remember being, we were outside the Hooters
the previous time, like the time before the last time I went
to Orlando, Florida.
And I remember because we couldn't go in because it was
really, It was like a strange, like, I don't know, there
were like so many people for some reason.
I think it was that like one party essentially took up the
entire restaurant.
They were like, it's a party of like 30 people.
You're going to have to wait a really long time.
And we were like, we're so hungry.
And I remember watching, oh my God, it was a really short
girl.
And she had the biggest dog dogs I've ever seen.
like seven plates and I was like this place is what this how
how does a place like this exist and I was like oh my god we
gotta go we're being did not no I'll wait forever for you
and so I was like oh man I really hope we can go back to
Hooters this last trip and we almost went And I don't, I'm
not going to name names.
I'm not going to say who denied us the beauty of, but they
made a good point.
She was like, I don't want to go to a restaurant that's
really loud and full of like crazy people.
I don't want to go to a bar.
I want to just relax and eat pizza.
So I get it.
But at the same time, I was hoping she would be there.
My short stack queen.
I'll always remember you.
And I've never been to a Hooters before!
I've never been to a Hooters before, so I've always just
been, like, so curious what it's like.
I don't even like wings.
I heard that that's the only reason to go, but...
Truly America's Maid Cafe.
And what kind of maid would I be if I could not go to the
American Maid Cafe?
What kind of maid cafe connoisseur would I be?
Huh?
Their fried pickles are pretty good.
See, I love fried pickles.
You're already selling it to me.
You are already selling it to me.
That's like insane gotcha look right there.
Oh, man.
Now you have to go for work.
It's market research, everybody.
Peppergun, welcome to Vemboosh.
ship.
Thank you.
I don't think Mint would fit in their uniforms.
This is kind of a Hooter's uniform, is it no?
Kind of.
Maybe.
Don't they wear like a tank top and shorts?
Minus the Hooters.
Sorry, I don't have birds in my room oh my gosh we're
shaming me i own cats and not birds i'm sorry we all deserve
a short stack queen in our life yeah could you make it a
vlog about it like the other mid cafe me vlogging my first
time at pooters the american mid cafe Do you think if I
asked them to bless my food, they would?
Hooters, Minto collab when we'd all go.
Minto needs to get a gray parrot.
I need to get my own Apollo.
I've heard from parrot owners that like, parrots are, like,
because I've thought about it, like I love watching parrot
videos, but I think it's similar to like, you know, you
watch a baby video and you're like, ah, but that doesn't
necessarily mean mean you want the baby you know what i mean
so i've watched parrot videos and i'm like ah maybe i want a
parrot and then i hear that they are just like toddlers like
they are they are so much work and be ready for all your
things to be chewed on and all the noise and all the mess
and everything and they live forever like twin peaks is kind
of hooters but more flannel wait that's even better i love
flannel jean short shorts as i recall went for a work lunch
once we just got all Billy with my Catholic good boy
co-worker.
What is so awkward?
They can touch you?
Did you gain a tale in your afterlife journey?
What do you mean by that?
Go to Twin Peaks.
Maybe I should go to Twin Peaks instead, then.
They're loud, smart, social, and needy.
Wait, needy is so cute, though.
attacking my PC mouse.
I want one so badly, but at the same time, I think with the
way that I stream for like long hours, it might be kind of
difficult.
Unless I had like my parrot in my room and like you could
hear him or something.
Cats are so easy.
They're very self-reliant,
it would be so I would be playing and you just hear
Bredded dragon You mean a bearded dragon?
I want a bearded dragon so badly I used to have a leopard
gecko and then my teacher when I was in elementary school
elementary school for you humans the over the holidays she
would let you take home the bearded dragon and so I got to
take him home for Christmas once and and I I I dressed him
up in like as like a Santa Claus and everything it was so
good my family have a great parrot he's a unique member of
the family but he is a lot of work a lot of noise and he
bites They also need a lot of company.
Oh, this sounds so fun.
I know.
They're like, it sounds so great.
And like the videos are so cute.
And then you're just like, there's so much work.
They are very much, much work.
And like, like I love there's this one bird that I watch
sometimes.
I can't remember his name, but he loves to go into the
cabinet of like where they keep the cups and stuff.
And they only have plastic cups because of this bird.
to knock them all outside of like he likes to like throw
them on the ground essentially and they're like but but he
gets the most satisfaction when the when his parents like
act like it's a bad thing so he'll like be he'll be pushing
the cups out of the cabinet and they're like oh my gosh
don't Oh my gosh!
And he's just like, and he'll go and knock another one out.
My name is Mito Phantom.
I'm a meadow.
I got to take home a class.
Tarantula over the summer!
I want to do.
You say cats are easy, but I just moved house and my cat has
been glued to me for days.
Okay, I have to confess something a little bit.
it.
I have to confess a little bit.
Today I started stream a half hour later than I was supposed
to, than I intended.
Before then, my migraine was coming back a little bit, so I
took a nap.
And when I woke up, my cat paused.
She never cuddles with me.
And she cuddled up by my leg.
And so I wanted to stay in bed for a little bit longer.
And I couldn't move And so I just wanted to stay with my cat
I wanted to stay with my cat Because she never cuddles with
me 100% forgiven I was so I can't even explain to you guys
how happy I was I was like no way She's She's Because she
jumped up on the bed, and I kind of was like, come here,
come here.
And then she actually listened.
She's very...
Oh, that was my controller disconnecting, sorry.
Totally worse.
Yeah, so...
I was so happy.
Is it you that had a cat you regret getting?
No.
Sounds like someone else.
Not guilty.
Did that carrier...
migraine you know i think it did mostly mostly i would have
been mad if you had moved i was so happy that she just came
to to snook with me i was like oh my gosh oh my gosh this
never happens any i've been trying to get her to like
because she really loves my roommate and she does not love
me she's my cat but she's always like sitting with my
roommate and so i was like okay maybe i can get her to sit
with me more please please love me love me oh well
bear sundere like that i guess that's true.
Have you tried eating catnip?
Like me?
Eat the catnip!
No.
What does catnip taste like?
I mean, probably just like grass, right?
Dried grass?
I haven't eaten grass once.
It's not good.
Isn't that one of those bamboozled flavors is grass?
That game is evil.
Have you heard of like some of the flavors that game has
it's like it's like they have like dirty bandage nasty minto
you are not the favorite i know and it hurts it hurts they
have terrible it's got barf yeah it's so gross i had the
spoiled milk one ew oh it's so just the name enough was to
make me gack i'd Like, dirty bandage is, like, foul.
That's horrible.
Oh, yeah, used bandage.
Used bandage.
That's foul.
Who's coming up with this?
Rip to the taste testers.
Oh, my God.
What do they put in there?
Like, oh, my God, I just opened up my phone and it was Keanu
Reeves' real name.
Let's see.
Bean boozled.
Liver and onions.
looks the same as cappuccino.
Old bandage looks the same as pomegranate.
Rotten egg looks the same as buttered popcorn.
Toothpaste, that one's not bad, that's just minty.
Looks the same as berry blue.
What?
Toothpaste isn't bad.
You literally have to stick that in your mouth to brush your
teeth.
Popcorn is also bad.
I think the buttered, probably the like fake buttered flavor
might make me feel sick.
I kind of want to know how people know what old bandages
taste like.
And the fact that the old bandage bean boozle, like the
little bean, is red.
It's so disgusting.
Barf looks the same as peach.
Stink bug looks the same as toasted marshmallow.
Bougar looks the same as juicy pear.
Dirty dishwasher.
Looks the same as a birthday cake.
Stinky socks looks the same as Toothie Fruity.
And dead fish.
Looks the same as strawberry banana smoothie.
And you know the worst part about this image that I'm
looking at?
The very bottom says, naturally and artificially flavored.
Which means some of these are naturally flavored.
They don't say which ones.
Sure, you could assume that it's just the yummy flavors,
but...
But...
What if...
What would your gross flavor creation be?
I think I'd go for mysterious shower drain clump.
Eww!
That's disgusting.
I don't even want to think about it.
It makes me gag.
It's so horrible.
Spoiled milk
Sewer right Maybe I would do like Bottom of a shoe or
something like that Where it's gross But like the name
itself doesn't make me Doesn't make me shiver
Ectoplasm Hey That's delicious What are you talking about?
Ectoplasmic spire.
Shoes aren't that dirty.
Uh-oh.
I don't know about that.
Maybe...
Just take one walk down the sidewalk of New York City.
And then say your shoes aren't that disgusting.
Seattle Gum Walk.
What is that?
Is that famous?
Ectoplasm.
Do you clean your shoes?
I don't think so.
No.
I mean, I wipe them off before I go into the main cafe.
And I take them off.
Once I'm inside.
So...
People lick the Seattle gum wall.
What is the Seattle gum wall?
Google, Seattle, Seattle, Seattle, I can't type, Seattle
Gumwall.
Holy!
Oh my god!
Why does this exist?
What the hell?
It kind of reminds me of how, like, people kiss Marilyn
Monroe.
Monroe's grave, which I'm like so many people are, are
kissing that thing.
You're gonna get something.
I'm so sorry, Minta didn't mean to teach you this.
Why is this like a tradition?
Why does that have to be gum?
Why can't it be the Seattle gum wrapper wall?
Like, it doesn't have to be actual gum.
It could be the wrapper.
That would be even prettier.
Eww!
We just had the damn wall cleaned up too.
What about kissing the blarney stone?
That's in, uh, what's it called?
Ireland, right?
What is, that gives you luck supposed to, right?
Blarney stone.
I heard, I, wait.
I've heard, I've seen that it's like really small.
Or something like, you have to, or rather you have to do
something really small.
strange for it like don't they like hang you off a side of a
cliff or something like as an irish man it does in fact give
luck and something else you have to lean backwards too many
kisses wearing it out over the years so if you got too many
kisses would your lips fall off would your lips disappear
my friend did that when he went to ireland i would never
let's test it you want to try it regrows oh okay humans are
like lizards that's the best good good
Did you answer this after all the kissing practice?
Okay, it was only a couple times.
How many times...
That should be a Mythbusters episode.
Bring back Mythbusters so we can see.
How many times do you have to be kissed for your lips to
fall off?
Supposed to give the gift of gab.
What is the gift of gab?
But yeah, you lie down and slide over the edge a bit.
Really not that scary.
Been there.
You did it!
It's not really a myth, Minkid.
Oh, it's science.
Okay, well, I'm gonna make my own show called Science
Experiments.
Explorers.
Explorers of science, the experiments that are, they could
be myths, but they're not.
But we still bust them.
That's the full title.
It's actually a light novel.
It will be turned into an anime next season.
Please watch my...
Please watch my show.
Spectral Science featuring Mint Phantom.
Hey, stop trying to workshop my name here, okay?
Of course...
Wait, what was the name again?
Uh...
What was it?
What did we call it?
Spectral... Wait, no.
That wasn't Spectral Science.
That's the fault.
That's the knockoff show.
The one that really rolls off the tongue well.
Make a show where they break all the bad theories.
Oh my gosh!
I heard something recently that, like...
There's a... There's a bean.
There's a bean in Breaking Bad that, like, they used to
poison...
They were trying to poison somebody with the bean.
And apparently people...
It does not work that way in real life.
But apparently people...
Yeah, the ricin.
The ricin.
People were trying it in real life to poison people with the
bean.
And it didn't work.
Because...
It's...
Hollywood, baby.
It's all dramatized.
Death by bean.
Oh!
Sorry.
Testing myths and science in another world?
Maybe we go to Breaking Bad World.
Thankfully it doesn't work.
Yeah, that's why you should never show someone how to
actually make a bomb or actually poison someone on TV
because people are gonna try it.
They were like, Breaking Bad is so realistic.
The Ryzen, it's gotta work.
That Ryzen Bane.
In the Saul Gumblin verse.
Don't watch Dr. Stone then.
Do they really?
They tell you how?
Rice and bean, rice and bean.
Wait, that sounds kind of good.
I want some rice and beans right now.
You gotta watch the Breaking Bad Mythbusters episodes.
They actually tell you how to dissolve a human body.
Wait, is that real?
That's real?
It's real.
Don't accept beans from strangers, people.
Yeah, it could be bean boozled.
And you could be getting...
You could be getting stink bug.
You could think that it's delicious toasting marshmallow.
But no, it's stink bug.
You just got bean boozled.
Minto love yippee.
Thank you.
Thank you so much for four months.
Who is Alan Wake?
He's an author.
Honestly, I want to play more already.
but I will resist I will resist until next week obviously
he's a writer what did I say did I say author my bad I I
elevated his title
author but he specifically says writer I'm a writer I take
out I'm a yapper.
I could say talker.
Oh my goodness.
Happy New Year, me and dog.
Here's to another year of fun.
Chris, thank you so much for 20 months.
Thank you.
Happy New Year.
Can't believe they made a berry-flavored bean.
Why would it...
Oh, the stink bug?
Oh, yeah.
Nasty.
A virtual tuber.
I'm stuck here in the virtual world.
I'm stuck in the virtual.
What is real?
Is my wife still even here?
I'm already so immersed in the story.
I want to keep playing.
But for now, I will.
I will leave you all here.
Thank you guys for hanging out with me.
I really, really appreciate it.
It was a bit of a shorter stream today, but Happy New Year
Minto and y'all Happy New Year for all good Thank you for
four months Thank you so much I just joined Oh my gosh,
there's a phrase for that In Japanese So when they say like
The stream is over Or you can use it at like shows and stuff
too But it's like the This is the last song Stuff like that
You say, KITABAKARI!
Which means like, I just got here!
KITABAKARI!
So...
Yeah.
Thanks for the stream.
Make sure to drink some tea or coffee so you're wide awake.
Wait, so you're wide-eyed and awake for the collab.
See you in the next.
Thanks, Argo!
Yeah, I need some...
I need some...
Some...
Some drink for my throat.
Kitabakari!
Is the Tensetsu BC's quiz over custody of Barry?
Or reverse custody?
Your turn to take the Barry.
What if Barry and I leave our respective groups and elope?
Nerala, thank you for the pink!
Close your eyes for a second and imagine a swarm slash pack
slash school of Aibu is rushing to hug you and You hugs us
all.
Oh my god, there's so many of you.
Oh my god, it's terrifying.
Oh my god, stay back.
It's a hug.
Ah, you're so squishy.
Oh god, there's too many of you.
I'm drowning.
I'm dead now.
How do you drown a ghost with a bunch of other ghosts,
maybe?
Anyway, that was silly.
Hello, wife!
Hello, that's cool!
Hello, hello, wife.
much for hanging out with me today i can't wait to continue
more alan wake next time just get ibu in your mouth yeah
they were so gummy um gummy a swarm of hungry ibu's can
strip a cow of its flesh in less than 15 seconds making them
the fourth fastest swarm predator on the planet yeah they go
around they're like like a cartoon it's like like that and
they like swarm it and just devour in 15 seconds It's really
impressive.
What's up, everybody?
I'll see you when I see you next.
There is a collab tonight.
So if I see you there, then I'll see you there.
And if not, then I'll see you later.
It's the next time.
Thank you, everybody.
Bye-bye.
Bye-bye-bye-bye-bye.
then and I will not say anything.
Beat to burn on a whole stomach.
Thank you.
Thank you for the spooky Akkadona.
Minkie, Minkie, Minkie, Minkie, Minkie, Minkie, Minkie,
Minkie, Minkie, Minkie, Minkie Minkie, Minkie, Minkie,
Minkie, Minkie, Minkie Minkie, Minkie Minkie, Minkie,
Minkie, Minkie.